comment la parole est au président
christian jacob
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre les attentats qui ont
frappé la france au coeur en 2015 sont
restés une plaie béante
ce que nous devons par dessus tout aux
victimes et à tous les français
c'est une détermination totale dans
notre lutte contre le terrorisme et
contre l'islamisme radical
vous savez monsieur le premier ministre
que le groupe parlementaire des
républicains a pris et prendra ses
responsabilités à chaque fois que s'agit
d'armes et la france contre le
terrorisme l'union nationale dans une
grande démocratie se construit entre
majorité et opposition
nous vous avions à deux reprises proposé
le vote de la déchéance de nationalité
après l'avoir refusée nous prenons acte
que vous acceptez enfin qu'un individu
qui portent les armes contre la france
n'est plus sa place dans notre
communauté nationale
comme je vous l'avais dit au congrès
nous pensons qu'une loi ordinaire
suffirait pour mettre en place cette
mesure est si vous rechercher l'unité
nationale elle doit commencer par
l'unité gouvernementale car les signes
que donne votre garde des sceaux ne sont
pas bons pour la cohésion nationale
nous sommes prêts à soutenir le projet
de loi constitutionnelle car c'est le
signe que la france n'accepterait plus
l'inacceptable mais nous n'accepterons
pas un marché de dupes où vous
trouveriez les français en votant le
principe de déchéance de nationalité
tout en repoussant son application aux
calendes grecques
ma question est donc très précise
monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous présenter simultanément à la
révision constitutionnelle
un projet de loi d'application parce que
sans cette loi d'application
l'engagement du président de la
république briffe à ce congrès ne serait
qu'une énième promesse non tenue
nous avons besoin vous le comprenez
monsieur le premier ministre d'un
engagement très clair de votre part
6 merci monsieur le président jacob la
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
au mieux elle va health le président
tous mes voeux pour cette année 2016 à
chacun d'entre vous bien évidemment le
président jacob
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
l'avais dit au cours de cette année 2015
notre pays a été touché en plein coeur
et ces derniers jours chacun d'entre
vous nous touchent souvent avec le
président de la république nous avons eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de
rendre hommage aux victimes des
attentats terroristes
les événements survenus la semaine
dernière devant un commissariat parisien
l'agression antisémite qui s'est produit
hier à marseille nous rappelle la
réalité de cette menace menace qu'il
concerne pas uniquement la france
nous le savons bien et le terrible
attentat qui s'est produit ce matin à
istanbul vient encore souligné combien
cette menace elle nous concerne elle
concerne l'europe elle concerne la
méditerranée elle concerne le monde
laissez moi ici nouvelle fois adressé
mon expression de solidarité vis à vis
des victimes de leur proche de la
turquie de nos amis allemands qui ont
été très durement touchée c'est ensemble
avec ces pays que nous combattrons bien
sûr le terrorisme et celle réalité vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président elle
nous oblige et nous oblige à être à la
hauteur de la situation
bien sûr le débat existe heureusement et
il y aura lieu ici même argument contre
argument car oui plus que jamais face au
terrorisme face à la menace la
démocratie doit vive mais celle réalité
nous oblige surtout à ne pas céder à la
facilité des fausses polémiques des
petites phrases et rechercher ses voûtes
chou et l'union c'est cet état d'esprit
républicain qui anime le président de la
république et le gouvernement
et c'est cet état d'esprit qui doit
continuer à nous animer tous le 16
novembre devant le congrès le président
de la république annoncé une révision de
la constitution pour protéger les
français dans la durée nous avons décidé
d'inscrire dans la constitution l'état
d'urgence et vous le savez vous l'avez
rappelé nous avons également proposé la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
personnes condamnées pour un crime
constituant une atteinte grave à la
nation sans pour autant créer la
situation d'apatrides tuer des français
au nom de l'islamisme radical du jihad
c'est se couper définitivement de la
communauté nationale et serge était au
fond toute volonté de vivre ensemble oui
alors l'état la république peuvent
prendre des mesures vous aurez à
débattre de ce texte dans les prochaines
semaines comme l'avait annoncé le
président république devant le congrès
je présenterai ce texte devant le
parlement et nous présenterons aussi les
deux textes
les deux lois qui doivent accompagner et
l'article 1 et l'article 2 de la
révision constitutionnelle
nous présenterons ces textes en même
temps nous avons encore quelques jours
devant nous pour une application qui
suivent il est hors de question d'y
perdre du temps quand les français
attendent de l'autre par des engagements
c'est ce que nous faisons
j'imagine que le ministre de l'intérieur
et reprendra cet après-midi en répondant
à vos questions nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir
tout à l'heure quand nous nous
rencontrerons à matignon oui alors à ce
moment là nous devons prendre des
décisions qui s'appliquent
le plus rapidement au possible c'est
ainsi que nous faisons vivre l'unité
nationale c'est ainsi que nous répondons
à l'exigence des français merci monsieur
le premier